oh my gosh you guys justine and caleb
you're in the
final what is going through your head
right now oh
just pure excitement like i really can't
even believe we're here
literally could not ask for a better
ending than to be here with her
it's been amazing yeah i know when you
first came in
you were worried that you were not gonna
find anybody yeah
it was one of those really emotional
times where i started to just like doubt
myself
and then this dude comes in uh she was
definitely on my radar
when i told her i couldn't tell if she
liked me or not yeah and uh
she put some action behind those words
what i'm hearing is the car wash
challenge really did it for you
so i was like if there was a time to
like really put myself out there and
get this guy to like look my way a
little bit i was like this is it
you put a lot more than your heart out
there i'll say that what do you think
one of your
highest moments was yesterday for sure
yeah just being completely open with
each other
and feeling comfortable enough to say
that we do love each other that was
probably
the biggest emotional high we haven't
really touched the word love in here and
so to hear him say it and just kind of
validate the feelings that i was feeling
as well
it was just amazing that was definitely
my highest
all right guys well thank you so much
for talking to me and i will see you in
a bit
you